- If you only buy your paper products
from Dunder Mifflin and
the gang at "The Office",
here are five other
titles worth checking out
on this week's "Binge Guide".
With eight of nine Fresh
seasons under its belt,
"The Office" has cemented itself
as one of the greatest
sitcoms of all time,
and is regaining popularity
with a new audience in the streaming age.
And with trips to places
like a parks department,
a sheriff's department,
and an IT department,
this list will fill your "Office" void,
starting with our Certified Fresh Pick,
"Parks and Recreation".
Premiering back in 2009,
this mockumentary following
the inner workings of a parks
and recreation department,
ran for seven mostly Certified
Fresh seasons on NBC.
And one of the show's
creators, Michael Schur,
has also brought us comedies like
"The Good Place" and "Brooklyn Nine-Nine",
both of which you should also check out.
Critics call this one
of the very best sitcoms
on television, praising
it for finding fresh ways
of utilizing its lovable ensemble
and for being heartfelt yet hilarious
and snarky yet good-natured.
You can binge this show
in just under 46 hours,
and don't forget the rest
of Michael Schur's comedies,
which should fill up your binge
calendar until about 2022.
Dialing in with our Editor's
Pick this week is "Reno 911!"
After six successful
seasons on Comedy Central
starting back in 2003,
this improvised show
about inept officers in a
county sheriff's department
returned this year for a
Fresh season run on Quibi.
The show, which also
spawned the 2007 film,
"Reno 911!: Miami", has
been praised by critics
for being an anarchically
hilarious ride along.
You can binge all seven
seasons and the movie
in about 36 and a half hours.
For our Throwback Pick this week,
we're heading back to 2012
for "The Mindy Project"
With six Fresh seasons,
three airing on Fox and three on Hulu,
this show is about a young OB/GYN
trying to balance her
professional and personal life
and trying to match the fairytale endings
of her favorite romantic comedies.
After kick-starting her
career on "The Office",
star and creator Mindy Kaling
shines in what critics call
a charming comedy, where
she earns consistent laughs
with her wit, charm, and physical comedy.
It'll take you about 54 and a half hours
to binge all six seasons,
and you will eventually learn
that real life is nothing
like a romantic comedy.
Remotely accessing our
Audience Pick this week
is "The IT Crowd".
This British comedy ran for
four seasons starting in 2006,
and it's about the humorous adventures
of a ragtag team of IT
workers at a huge corporation
that's headed by a temperamental yuppie.
Critics say that this show,
which helped launch the
career of Chris O'Dowd,
is a brainy riot that is
consistently funny and inventive.
You can binge this one in just
about 10 and a half hours,
but if you do it on your work computer,
you actually might hear from IT.
And, finally, our Brand-New
Pick this week is "Superstore".
This NBC workplace comedy
with five Fresh seasons,
and a brand-new sixth season,
follows employees working
at a big box store
while taking a comedic approach
to timely, more heavy issues.
With a charming cast led by
the Emmy-winning America Ferrera,
critics call "Superstore"
one of the most lovable
ensembles on television.
You can binge the first five
seasons in just over 37 hours,
which is about the same amount of time
you need to walk every aisle
at your local superstore.
Okay, hopefully this list will help
firm up your next few binge sessions.
That's what she said!
Let us know what you're currently
streaming in the comments
and be sure to check out the
new "Rotten Tomatoes is Wrong",
a podcast from Rotten Tomatoes,
because Fresh and Rotten
is just the beginning of the conversation.
New episodes drop every Thursday,
and you might be looking at
one of the hosts of the show.
We'll see you back here
for more recommendations
based on the shows you love
on the Rotten Tomatoes' "Binge Guide"!
(funky music)